and I'll mention I've been with the CFPB
now for about nine months and it's a
I've been doing public service for over
20 years embarrassing to admit it
sometimes and the really really
interesting thing about the CFPB is that
the public service that I do is so
tangible I worked for the federal
reserve system and i work on financial
stability and you do a lot of good works
but it's really hard to tell people hey
we set good interest rates this month
and have that really be tangible at the
CFPB a lot of the work is really really
tangible and I'm going to start by
giving a very short overview of consumer
protection and people will recognize all
of these different agencies and I want
to point out that the top on the Food
and Drug Administration that agency
really the prompt behind that agency was
Upton Sinclair's book the jungle about
the the disgusting habits of the the
meatpacking industry and if you move
down a little bit further to 1966 the
the national traffic and motor vehicle
safety many of you would remember Ralph
Nader's book unsafe at any speed and
that was really the prompt that got this
particular consumer protection going for
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
it was the most recent financial crisis
we came out of the dodd-frank act as as
one of the two new agencies that are
really designed to one protect financial
stability and to the CFPB to protect
consumers of prime an shal products I'm
going to talk a I'll give an overview of
the CFPB and I'm going to talk about the
data that we have at the CFPB and what
we're doing with that data and how the
analysis that we're doing is actually
impacting your daily life not just the
daily life of the average American but
it will have an impact
on probably everyone in this room's life
at some point so an overview of the the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau we
were created by the dodd-frank act in
2010 took about a year to stand up the
agency so we're really about four years
old right now our mission is to help
consumers of financial products and
services probably everyone in this room
has taken out a loan either for a car or
a mortgage or an education probably most
of you have a credit card and I don't
know if you've tried to read your kereta
card plans but sometimes they're a
little complicated you all have have
bank accounts you'll have debit cards
and all of these are products that you
want to be able to use effectively and
not be taken advantage of so we have a
couple of missions and I'll talk about
that a little bit more but the main
thing is we want to make the consumer
financial product markets available and
usable for American consumers but we
also want to ensure that the regulations
that the financial institutions have to
follow are easy to follow if you've ever
had to read a regulation it's a
nightmare they're really hard to
understand and part of what will help
consumers is if thanks and other types
of financial institutions can understand
the rules they'll be better able to
implement them so an overview of the
CFPB I like to say we educate we enforce
and we study and I'm going to talk about
a number of of data stories in a couple
of minutes and throughout those data
stories you'll see the theme educate
enforce and study so having worked at
other financial regulators I've dealt
with the study and the enforced mission
before one of the things that I find
really unique about the CFPB and that I
really really like is the educate
mission it's not just force banks to
comply with laws and regulations it's
not just study financial markets and
figure
how things work and how to make them
work better but it's also how do you
educate individuals so that they can
make good financial decisions one of the
things we talk about sitting around
tables at the office is people will shop
for a house they'll go they'll look at
every feature they'll negotiate the
price of the house they'll look at all
of the details and and and really work
over like every thousand dollars towards
the price of that house but when it
comes time to actually finance the house
a lot of people will put that decision
in somebody else's hand it's complicated
it's hard and not everybody has has the
the confidence in the background to
really make a sound financial decision
so we want to provide tools and
information and education so that people
can make this very very important
decision with the tools that they need
so what do we do at the CFPB with our
data we collect consumer complaints and
I'm going to talk about that in a minute
and I'll mention that we just had a Time
magazine just did an article about the
CFPB and called us the agency that's got
your back which was actually kind of
cool and fun and that's because of our
consumer complaints we inform rulemaking
with with data you can't make good rules
without a lot of information and
analysis behind it we study financial
markets economists like to say markets
are optimized and people behave the way
that they should but in reality we all
know that that people don't always
behave in an optimal way so we like to
see how do people really behave when
they're making financial decisions so
that we can write rules that actually
help people in the way that they
actually behave when it's necessary
we'll go and enforce that financial
institutions actually
do what the laws require and sometimes
that means bringing them to court and we
have a lot of if you went to the CFPB's
website we have a lot of cases where
we've gone to court and we've actually
sued companies and we've gotten money
back for consumers and then we also
supervised financial institutions to
ensure that they're complying with the
laws I'm going to talk about the
consumer complaint database for a minute
and this has been one of our flagship
data data assets we collect any anyone
in this room can go on the internet and
if you have a problem or a concern with
a financial institution that you're
engaging with maybe you think your bank
charged you access fees may be repaid
alone that they're saying you didn't
repay maybe there's some whatever your
problem is with a financial institution
you go in and submit a complaint and
that complaint gets reviewed by an
investigator every complaint gets vetted
we go to the actual financial
institution and say what do you think
about this complaint in some cases
there's remediation is is made to an
individual consumer and in other cases
you can imagine there's complaints where
yes that that's not a great thing that
happened to you but nothing illegal
happened or nothing inappropriate
happened the other really nice thing
about this complaint database is not
just that we investigate these
complaints we make a lot of the data
public so from the beginning and we
currently have about 650,000 complaints
from the time we started this database
am from the beginning we've published
what we would call the structured data
what's the financial institution that
the complaint was again what kind of a
complaint was it was it you know a debt
collection complaint was it a an unfair
lending complaint we've published the
the structured data associated with it
but what's really really valuable in
this data is the narrative
information the story that the people
are telling about this and that's where
you get a lot of the information so
there's always the the mix between you
want to put information out there for
the public to use but you also want to
protect people's privacy so this is
where the data analytics comes in we did
we needed to figure out how could we
publish these narratives while
protecting consumers privacy and the
last presentation at that anonymity was
actually tied right into it and he
talked about redaction so we went
through and we did machine learning and
and natural language processing to
redact so if you look at here where I
don't know how well you can see it but
we've got a lot of stuff that's xed out
and how did we do that we don't have
somebody going in and manually with the
black marker Xing things out we took
test data sets where we figured out what
were the patterns of words that were
problems um if there's account numbers
if there's social security numbers
anything that were potential problems
and we we ran these through and and we
did the machine learning along with the
natural language processing to be able
to programmatically scrub these now
we're putting this out on the web so we
do do a manual review before things
actually get put out on the web to make
sure that we've captured what we want
but the benefits of doing this
programmatically is my computer never
has it's never tired it doesn't work
better in the morning than it does in
the evening it's uh it's it's always
consistent so by doing it
programmatically we catch a lot more of
the information rather than somebody
doing this manually and it's faster and
of course less expensive so I promised
to tell a couple of data stories about
what what the work that we're doing
and so from the consumer complaints we
go in and we analyze and we're working
on tools right now that will do that
help investigators to analyze these data
650,000 complaints going through
narratives is a nightmare to try and do
any sort of analysis on the breadth of
information so we're creating analytics
tools using elastic search and solar and
other products to help the investor
natives go through and actually search
for common types of complaints or trends
and so one of the things we found from
our complaints database was a number of
complaints where service members were
being taken advantage of so this is a
copy of a press release that we have
about where we actually went out and we
sued some companies and we got a million
dollars back for service members for
either unfair illegal practices another
data story this is actually my very
favorite data story mostly because it
was such a cool analytical engagement so
we took the consumer complaint data a
lot of people complained about getting
cited for their credit reports we're
getting dinged because they had medical
debt outstanding and I'll talk a little
bit about medical debt in just a minute
so we took a lot of the consumer
complaint data we took structured credit
data about consumers we did interviews
of health care professionals and we did
a lot of literature reviews to figure
out how does medical debt in billing
work this was a fascinating study
combining all of those different types
of data so I'm sure you can imagine the
complexities that went into that but
what we found is that medical debt is
different from other types of debt and
it does not act as good a predictor as
other types of debt delinquency
why is that it's probably obvious well
I'm right now I'm dealing with the fact
that my husband's physical therapist is
arguing with our insurance company and
he was threatened last night that well
if you don't pay us this is going to go
on your credit record and I said bring
it on because we're covered for that but
a lot of times in medical debt there are
you are actually responsible you're
you're deemed responsible for that
outstanding debt while the insurance
company and the service provider are
debating about how much are they going
to pay and who has to pay what and so
what we found through the complaints
database was sometimes people didn't
know that they their credit records were
being gained until they actually looked
at their credit report there's also
unlike not paying your rent or not
paying your credit card bills medical
debt often comes up because of something
sudden and extreme and somebody who is
perfectly willing to pay that may not be
able to pay it in full on day one
whereas your rent you know you can plan
for and there's events that happened
that caused problems in that so by doing
this study what we found was that
medical debt is different and it's not a
good predictor of willingness or ability
to to pay your debts there were a couple
of results for them from this and my
favorite is that this actually this this
really shows the benefit of study and
educate because without the CFPB having
to go in and do any sort of regulation
or any sort of mandate by publishing
this study FICO one of the leading
credit scores changed the way that it
calculated its credit score to discount
medical debt it didn't eliminate it from
the from the algorithm but if it saw
that because medical debt is not as good
a predictor as other types of
at or delinquencies is actually the the
term I should be using it changed the
way it did it we didn't require it but
they saw because we did this study and
we evaluated these markets that this is
something that should change so this is
actually one of my favorite data stories
I'm going to talk a little bit about
mortgage data anyone who lived through
the the financial crisis in the 90s or
the most recent financial crisis knows
that mortgages had a role to play in
this we've been collecting mortgage data
we the regulatory community collectively
for many many many years probably 20
years the CFPB now after the dodd-frank
act got the responsibility for
collecting this data one of the really
fabulous things about the mortgage data
is that almost all of it is public data
so on this website you can actually
download the data what I would like to
show is on one I'll tell a data story
about how another agency HUD the housing
Urban Development I think is anyone here
work for HUD okay good then you can't
correct me they use these other agencies
use this data as well as the public uses
this data and so what HUD did is they
went in and used the the humdum mortgage
data hum the stands for Home Mortgage
Disclosure Act mortgage data along with
some other data to identify areas that
needed emergency assistance and so the
benefit of doing this analysis is that
areas that might have otherwise really
been been underutilized or or abandoned
or become a blight on the community
because HUD was able to recognize where
these places were they were able to go
in and do do redevelopment
programs in those areas so I'm going to
talk a little bit more about the hum de
data because we make it public and i'm
just going to show you and that did not
work what I'm sorry we're still on the
complaint database aren't we you haven't
seen any of my slides oh you did okay I
should be able to get to oh I'm sorry
I'm not a Mac user so okay I wanted to
show this particular website because i
like the visualizations that we do on
this particular website where because
the data is public you could actually
download the data and look at it any way
you want but it's kind of nice to see
here this is sales of mortgage and
refinancing startups but when you look
at the overtime it's actually pretty
interesting information you can also go
in and you could drill down into your
area what's going on over time so I
thought I would just demo that a little
bit back sorry
okay I talked about the educate mission
a couple of times and you'll you you'll
hear that theme again and again we want
to create tools and we need to use data
to create tools that will help consumers
make good financial decisions one of my
favorite web parts of our website I'll
also mention here that because we have
this educate mission one of the other
ways we use data is we do a lot of web
analytics we do more web analytics than
most of the other government agencies
that I've ever dealt with because we're
really interested in who's coming to
what page and how effective is our
education information so when I got to
the CFPB I was actually quite impressed
with the types of web analytics that
we're doing we're looking at how much
time is someone spending on a given
website because if they're just clicking
through they're not getting the
information but if they're spending time
on the website it's a better indication
that they're actually getting the
information that they need from from
this particular website so we have
owning a home lots of people buy houses
they as I mentioned before they spend a
lot of time negotiating the actual price
of the house and then they don't spend
as much time on on figuring out how to
how to actually finance this purchase
and I apologize because this is not my
so I wanted to just show real quickly
this is real simple data underlying some
of these visualizations but it can be
really powerful information so most
people when they go in and they're
they're trying to get a loan they don't
really know what the rates are in their
area and they don't know what the rate
what
they should expect for a rate so what we
did is we took some data and we we threw
it on here and we said four different
credit ratings whatever your credit
score is and for wherever you're located
like this is in Alabama we could look up
TC um what are you likely to have to pay
for an interest rate and so obviously
depending on your credit score what you
have to pay is likely to change so and
where where what state you're in is
likely to be a deciding factor in the
rate that you're going to pay so this
doesn't tell you this is certainly not
all the information that you need to
make a mortgage decision but it's giving
you an idea of what you should be
looking for in terms of raids so with
the current rates are I can't read that
like the highest one is is five percent
there if you go to a lender and he's
offering a six percent rate you should
not talk to that lender even if somebody
recommended this particular lender you
should know that there are better rates
available in your area so we're trying
to create tools that will help consumers
make these better decisions there's also
a ton of textual educational information
behind here that talks about like what
are points and how should you include
these these in your your decision
factors and sorry I'm trying to get back
to the
I think next time I won't toggle between
okay and finally I'll talk about data
that we use for enforcing so there are
bad actors out there in the world that
take advantage of either loopholes or
consumers who are not you know as
understanding of what they are of they
may need to know and there's also times
when people when corporations don't
necessarily know that they're not
complying with all the rules and
regulations so this is an example where
we are data scientists helped out with
this particular enforcement action
because debt collectors are not allowed
to call you at three o'clock in the
morning every night there's rules around
debt collection and so our data
scientists the step that they had to
take was there was a lot of complaints i
believe and there was a reason to
believe that debt collection was being
done inappropriately so when we went in
investigated this there was there was
several things we investigated for but
one of them was was calls in the middle
of the night for people who had
outstanding debt you can't just assume
that because someone's area code on
their phone actually indicates where
they live especially now with cell
phones and companies don't always have
people's addresses so we had to figure
out how could we normalize where do
people live so we took a bunch of
information and then normalized where
the zones were that people were living
to be able to do this study to see was
there a problem with the debt collection
and you can see here that we did
discover a number of of problems with
the the student loan servicing practices
and we got money back for consumers
again so
summarize and i see i'm almost at a time
that we use data to educate we use data
to figure out how to do a better job
educating and who who we are educating
we use data to enforce such as in the
last example and we use data to study we
need to study markets we need to study
what would be the impact of different
types of rules that that we we might
impose to ensure that we get the results
that we want rather than than unintended
consequences so that's all I have to say
about the CFPB in our data